quel garçon étiez vous à l'âge de 7 ans
c'est plutôt c'est pas de la mémoire
c'est de l'archéologie quelqu'un c'est
justement c'était quelqu'un qui j'étais
quelqu'un qui a commencé à écrire il a
commencé à écrire des poèmes
alors je veux pas que votre public
devient soupçonnait de moi immédiatement
je veux dire mon père est un poète un
grand poète
alors qu'est ce que le fils d'un poète
peut faire imiter son père
donc dès que j'ai commencé à écrire j'ai
commencé à écrire des poèmes puis
évidemment on habitait à la campagne à
1,5 km de la ville de parme et j'allais
à l'école à la campagne mes amis étaient
les fils des paysans qui habitait autour
de quelques ouvriers qui habitait dans
ce petit village et voyez mon père était
très très important dans ma formation je
crois que je lui dois tout presque dans
ma famille il ya quelques lieux quelque
chose qu'aujourd'hui je peux dire été
assez terrible qui était la rime options
de l'agressivité qu'on dit le
refoulement de l'agressivité jamais
entendu mon père et ma mère crie crié
l'un vers l'autre
donc tout un tout à coup je me suis
retrouvé dans la vie réelle où tout le
monde était très agressive et j'étais un
peu 101 sans défense met donc à donc
avec mon père et j'ai tué même des pères
dans le cinéma justement parce que je
pouvais pas dans la vie arrivé à des
confrontations violentes au fort la
rencontre avec pia parle pas aux lignes
est très importante
j'aimerais bien comprendre
comment il s'est passé parce que disant
que tout autour de vous dix ans c'était
un milieu cultivé bourgeois sensible
mais pas solide
c'était autre chose quand même il avait
un regard c'est une sorte de poète
radicales comme la mort de pasolini a
évolué durant vide terrible dans la
culture italienne
il y a eu personne qui est venue à
remplir ce vide après mais quand même il
avait tout compris
il avait compris qu'on allait vers une
forme de monoculture du beaucoup à la
télévision qu'on allait vers une sorte
de étouffement et sinon pire de
destruction et anéantissement des
petites cultures vous voyez moi
j'habitais à parme reggio emilia et à
moins de 30 km et sont de vils
complètement différente avec des
cultures différents je sais pas que ce
que ça ce qui reste en italie de cette
différence culturelle et c'est ce qui va
se passer en ce moment qu'on parle de la
grille même de traits d'un tarif le
fameux gâteau les fameux gâte et je
crois qu'il a le danger qui va se passer
au point de vue de cinéma et de la
télévision la même chose que c'est passé
un peu en europe avec cette sorte de
sein des petites cultures locales qui
était la richesse de notre pays
alors ma dernière question c'est de
savoir après tant de films différents
enrichissant est ce que vous estimez
mieux connaître bernardo bertolucci vous
même si c'était moi je pense que je suis
le dernier à comprendre mes films je
mets beaucoup de temps à le comprendre
en effet les discussions avec les autres
mais beaucoup
je sais pas s'il ya quelque chose à
comprendre à moi au delà de qui est dans
mes films je crois que mes films son
histoire de ma vie et la meilleure des
liens à prendre des comprimés film on a
compris
[Musique]